Thank you very much. It's a pleasure
to be back here. Thank you for coming.
Why don't you start by telling us
about about the book. I mean, they're,
in some ways, my, um,
my 2017 therapeutic writing
Trump mishegoss stories.
They, I didn't plan any of
them. They, they, uh, all
just sort of blurted out. Uh,
so unauthorized bread
is a story about people.
I'm refugee housing where all the
appliances are designed to have DRM,
to lock them into a vendor ecosystem so
you can only toast, authorize breading,
your toaster. You can only
store authorized groceries
in your fridge and so on.
And um, it, it, that is bad enough.
But then the hedge fund that owns the
backend for all this stuff financially
engineer's itself into bankruptcy
and so everything stops working.
And so,
uh,
they learn to jailbreak their appliances
out of necessity and then out of sheer
joy of,
of seizing the means of information.
But then they learned that the companies
are being rebooted out of bankruptcy
and that very soon their telemetry is
going to detect that the devices were
jailbroken and then they're going
to face the MCA criminal liability.
And because they're
all in refugee housing,
that will mean being
deported and possibly killed.
And so it becomes this like very high
stakes fight where this woman who has
created this kind of,
you know,
youth brigade of kids who go around and
jail break everyone's devices now has to
convince these kids who are completely
foursquare against it to go and restore
everything to factory defaults
without scaring the pants off of them.
They end up working with friendly texts
and trying to figure out if there's a
way that they can use vms to cheat
the telemetry and so on. So it's a,
it's a novel about, about
the kind of class dimension
and surveillance dimension,
a vendor Lockin,
uh,
and the way that that plays out depending
on what kind of privilege you have in
the world.
Um,
and then the next story is a story
called radicalize the title story.
And it's about,
um,
super entitled Middle Class White
Dudes who watched their loved ones die
preventable illnesses because
their insurers won't cover
therapies and who find
themselves on these darknet message boards
where they're radicalized into being
suicide bombers who kill
healthcare executives.
And in the end,
a lot of it is about whether or not
America will ever call a white due to
terrorist. Uh, and,
and some of it is about how just the
cause actually turns out to be and, and,
and so on.
And also this very toxic observation
that many have made about the incell
movement that, um, in normal support
message boards, you know, if you're,
if you're a recovering alcoholic and
you're in a, an an online community,
all the elder states,
people of that community are people who,
who beat the thing you're struggling
with and are now staying alive,
staying around to guide people.
But people who recover from being in cells
don't hangout an insult message board.
So all the elder states,
people have the incell message.
Communities are the most
toxic, most broken people.
And they're the ones saying,
yeah, a van, and drive it
through the streets and kill
as many people as you can.
They deserve it. Right? And so these
communities don't get better over time.
They get worse. And, and that's the kind
of community that I'm exploring. Um,
the third story is called model minority.
And it's about a thinly veiled analog
to superman intervening in a, um,
a beating by the same cops who killed
Eric Garner on Staten Island, uh,
who then discovers that the fact that
he's viewed as both a white and a human
are super contingent and that there are
some things that America won't tolerate,
uh, from the people who are
honorarily, white and human.
And it takes the form, uh,
in large part of Socratic
dialogues with Bruce Wayne,
who's a military contractor who provides
predictive policing software to, uh,
the end YPD and who's in fact
basically responsible for all of this.
And then the last story is a story called
the mask of the red death named after
the Edgar Allan Poe
story. And it's about, um,
preppers who build a luxury bunker just
outside of Phoenix and repair to it as
soon as the, the catastrophe
hits and, um, uh, you know,
fancy themselves living at a kind of
boy's own adventure of the elite surviving
while all the useless takers a die in
Phoenix because they didn't have the
wisdom to prepare these bolt holes,
but who in fact ended up
dying of cholera because they,
the useful people are the people who
stay behind in Phoenix and got the
sanitation working again.
And these Uber mentioned have,
have to discover that you
can't shoot germs. I was
originally going to be called,
you can't shoot terms,
but I think masque of the red death
has got the appropriate gravitas.
So it's these four novellas, they're
all linked. They, they, they,
they wrap around a lot of the same themes.
They touch in a lot of the
same geographic locations. Um,
some of the details Ricoeur writes.
So some of the op sec that superman
uses to avoid being, having his,
his secret identity added by the NSA,
he's got like a randomizer that tells
him where to take off from so that you
can't draw a map to see where superman is
always cited by, you know, ground radar.
Uh, so he know he runs very quickly to
somewhere else and then takes off. Um,
and this prepper has also got a randomizer
that makes him get in his disguise,
armored up, uh, uh, like
F-150 with a camper bed, uh,
that is full of all of his prepper gear
and put some fishing rods in the front
and just drive it off of
his gated community at this
randomizer is interval so
that there isn't someone
who goes, hey, that's weird.
Why is that guy driving his F-150
out of this gate guard a community?
Now he must be going to
his prepper hidey hole.
We'll follow him there and kill him
and take his stuff. So you know,
a lot of those,
a lot of the same things kind of repeat
and repeat and the things wrapper and
each other. It's, we're not using the
word collection, uh, for it. It's a,
it's just a fiction
book. Um, and it's, uh,
it's been likened by my publisher to
the book that Stephen King wrote. Um,
where that,
that the body,
the story that became a standby
me comes out of four seasons.
That's just for thematically connected
but not continuity connected.
Uh,
Tales.
Had any of the story's
been published previously?
No, this is all original stuff. Uh,
and as I say, wasn't planned. I,
I, you know, the unauthorized bread,
originally I sent it to my editor because
it was such a weird and awkward length
that I didn't think, I didn't know
what to do with it when it was done.
It's 30,000 words long. And I thought
that he was going to say, well,
we don't know what to do with this.
And instead he sent me an email
like the next day saying, oh my God,
this is amazing and timely.
We want to publish it in two months
as a standalone book. And I said,
well that's great.
Let's do that and we want to pay you
more than you got for your first three
novels for, which was also great. And
then, and then I sent him the next one,
I sent him the model minority. It
was like, this is also awesome.
We'll do it the next month as
a standalone. And I'm like,
I've got two more in the works.
So that's how we came to weight
about seven months to do it and,
and publish them all in one go topic.
Who are the,
the TV and movie studio associated with
the same company that owns the intercept.
A have bought the TV rights
for this inner developing and
now, and you mentioned timeliness
and reading unauthorized bread.
It seemed very much of the now and in
the book also struck me as being more
political,
which is kind of a funny thing to say.
Your work has always been political
in one way or another. Uh,
freedom of access to information,
doing it yourself.
But this one seems a little
more pointedly political.
Two things have happened.
One is that politics would
be just become more salient,
right? Like we are just in a moment
where you can't not talk about politics,
you know,
for better or for worse.
The other thing is that the political
dimension of information has now become
much more obvious,
right?
Like I don't know if any of you
work in like Ux or or or Ui design.
There's this thing that happens with
Ui design UX where like when you start,
you're trying to convey a bunch of ideas
that are really novel to the people who
you're conveying them to write.
Like you know,
if you think about it early gooeys like
just the idea that there is a file and
then that a file is a thing that you save,
right?
And that you have reversion and you have
control z and like all of those things
are kind of novel ideas.
Undo is not a thing that you just know
about if you've never used a computer and
do as like it's a weird idea.
And over time we got better at conveying
with those ideas mean but also the
urgency of conveying them is diminished,
right?
Because people are meeting you halfway
right now. Like just everybody,
people who don't know what a
floppy disk is, knows that oh no,
that a floppy disk means safe. Right?
And that just that icon like doesn't,
it doesn't need a tool tip
anymore the way it used to.
And in the same way like writing political
fiction about information doesn't
require nearly so much handholding.
You can just like jump
right in because you know,
in an age of black lives matter
and mimetic warfare and um,
uh, you know, questions about, um, uh,
whether or not our power grid is
vulnerable to a cyber attack and so on,
like talking about inflammation as being
this like important dimension to our
politics is,
is not a radical idea anymore.
And that means that you can dig
into like more nuance, right?
Like more the can be centered
more because the information dimension
is just obvious. That's interesting. It.
It also made me remember that it struck
me while reading the story that seems
slightly more educational than past
fiction has been there several sections.
Uh, it's not overly heavy exposition
but you go pretty detailed into digital
copyright kind of aside
how to jailbreak DRM. It,
it seems like you were educating
through the story as well.
So I think there's two dimensions to that.
One is like I think people are tolerant
of exposition when it's news you can use,
right?
Like oh that's how that works now a
whole bunch of stuff in my life suddenly
makes sense.
Like here's what a VM is or whatever.
The other thing though is that there
is a longevity that comes from writing
fiction where the technology is rigorous.
Like we've had a certain amount of
technological breakthrough in all of our
careers and lives,
but there are some like fundamentals
that remain pretty fundamental like you
know,
complexity and [inaudible]
and our understanding of
complexity theory and things
at scale and order and squared and things
that scale in polynomial time and so
on. Like those are things that
are just semi immutable. Right.
And so like talking about the kind of
problems we can solve and the kind of
problems we can't solve.
If you make the plot turn on them,
the plot doesn't get old in
the same way that it does.
If the plot turns on how much
Ram your phone has, right?
Like that's a moving target. But like
Turing completeness, not a moving target,
right?
Like writing about the fact that if you
try to design a computer that can run
all the programs except one you are trying
to do something that runs counter to
the really the only functional widespread
architecture we have for computers,
which is the one that runs all the
programs. And so there will, uh,
it will always be this like weird
mashed up Rube Goldberg under the hood.
If you've got a computer that doesn't,
that, that runs everything except one.
And it's always going to have like
certain recurring characteristics, right?
Like if you design a computer that has
a mode that sits below super user mode,
right?
Like a ring minus one where programs
execute that even the administrator of the
computer isn't supposed to be
able to inspect or terminate,
then that will always be a zone that if
someone who is an attacker gets access
to it, that they'll be able to operate
with total impunity and undetectable.
He against you because it's
a computer design not to,
not to introspect about processes that
are running in some ways and so like this
just keeps coming up,
right?
We keep designing computers that have
as part of their security model, oh,
there are programs that the user,
even if the user is the
administrator and owns the device,
can't terminate her inspect and inevitably
someone who's a bad actor starts
running code in it.
Like maybe the politburo orders apple
to run processes that seek out and
terminate VPNs that it can't
spy on for Ios devices in China,
which is like a thing that happened,
right? Like the, you know, this is,
this is the world's most predictable
outcome of putting that gun on the mantle
piece in act one.
But we're going to continue to put that
gun on the mantle piece in act one.
And so if you write science fiction that
turns on the actual characteristics of
computers like our theoretical
understanding computers
that science fiction
remains futuristic for so long as we
continue to make dumb policy choices about
computers, which you know, uh,
to to my great dismay probably means
that the fiction will remain current in
some way forever, right? Like little
brother is still being taught and read it.
I wrote it 13 years ago now and like the
question of whether or not subjecting
whole populations to surveillance are
using machine learning to make inferences
about guilt or,
or any of these other things creates
a bunch of path pathologies. Those,
those facts are like still totally
in evidence. They show no sign of,
of going away. We have totally
failed to learn the lessons of them.
The stakes only get higher and every
year there's another news hook that that
makes people read little brother.
And then come back to me and say, oh,
this is just like that
thing that you and you know,
how did you anticipate 13 years later
that we'd be doing this? And I'm like,
I didn't, we were doing it
13 years ago. We, we just,
we have like our literally still
beating our heads against that wall.
We will are figuratively still beating
our heads against that wall and we will
never stop.
And so little brother will remain current
and relevant for so long as we are
stupid about technology policy.
You mentioned the word route.
What was the initial idea for the story?
Like did it start with the phrase
unauthorized bread or did it come from
somewhere else? Yeah, it actually,
it started with a short story.
I wrote it as part of my guardian column,
so I'd been arguing for a long time
with people about Ios and the APP store
business model. And uh, there was this,
it just works.
And I trust them element to,
to people saying I want to work
within an ecosystem. And I,
I d I d I trust apple and I don't care,
uh,
if they have made choices about what I
can and can't use because I think those
choices are good ones. They're good
proxies for my interest. And I would,
and I was trying to tease
out the difference between
having a checkbox in your
[inaudible] that says,
I would like to do something that the
manufacturer has an approved and having
legal liability attached to figuring out
how to reconfigure eos to do something
that that hasn't been approved and
what kind of bad things crop up if it's
actually a felony to modify your oh,
to do things at the
manufacturer doesn't like.
And so I wrote a little story called if
dishwashers where I phones and it was in
the form of an open letter from a,
from a Steve Jobs,
the and CEO of a next generation Iot
dishwasher company called disher who make
an appearance in this story.
And he was explaining that like foodborne
illness has killed more people than
any other killer in human history.
And how can you expect your dishwasher
to be truly effective at keeping you safe
and making your dishes clean with the
least amount of water in an age of scarce
resources.
If you are able to put any old dish
that you want in your dishwasher.
And that is why you shouldn't be bending
the prongs of your dishwasher or trying
to take the RFIDs out of the dishes that
you bought from the disher store and
putting them in grandma's China and so on.
Because like you could buy a different
dishwasher if you wanted that. And,
and if you, uh, and,
and the deal that you got when you
bought this dishwasher was that you would
only wash dishwashers
from the kitchen store.
And the kitchen store works only with
licensed partners who make high quality
gear and they, they, you know,
anyone who wants can buy a $99 kitchen
store license and they can, they provided,
they comply with the terms of service.
They can make pottery that you
can put in your dishwasher,
but it's not dishwasher.
The fact that it says dishwasher safe
doesn't mean it's dishwasher safe, right?
They,
it's only when they're in our developer
program that we can tell you that you
truly won't die of Listeria. Uh, if you,
if you use their dishes and like
these are all like taken individually,
not unreasonable statements,
but they gang up to inkjet
printers for everything, right?
Everything is tied into some ecosystem
where you can't, you, you know,
it's not that you, you do trust
them, it's that you must trust them.
And if they ever make a decision that
you don't like, um, you are out of luck.
And the longer you go inside the
ecosystem, the more sunk costs you have.
And the harder it is the, you know,
the more you have to give away,
the more the switching cost is. If you
decide that you no longer trust them.
And so you end up being beholden to a
series of commercial decisions being made
in board rooms that you
have no insight into.
And you just have to trust that no one
in the firm will ever do anything that
runs counter to your interests.
And you know, like, I'm not, uh,
on anti-apple person.
I actually have a sad mac tattooed on my
arm from when I used to be a CIO and I
used to order $1 million worth of
APP apple gear a year. But you know,
as someone who's bought a fair number of
Apple Lemons and written pos for a fair
number,
a low number of apple lemons over the
years and seeing how the company can be
wildly imperfect and will
be wildly and perfect again,
I think the idea that you are trusting
them in this way that requires that you
trust them and that you can't transfer
your trust out actually invites future
leaders of the firm to make choices
because in the knowledge that if they,
that they can be, uh, uh,
they can betray your trust and you're
not gonna be able to leave, right.
That you'll be, that, that they,
they've got a lot of headroom in terms
of betrayed trust before you get to the
point where people are going to give up
a whole ecosystem of devices and replace
all of it. And certainly in
some customers may be never.
And I saw this not being looked on
with horror by the rest of the world,
but being looked on as kind of a,
uh, an excellent idea. So you know,
you have for example,
Johnson and Johnson getting approval for
an artificial pancreas. This is a uh,
closed loop, a continuous
glucose monitor and a, an um,
an insulin pump with some machine learning
to try and time the insulin dosing to
keep your blood sugar within a safe range.
Um,
and it uses proprietary insulin
cartridges, right? And you know,
it making a tool to refill
those cartridges is a
potential DMC a violation with
a $500,000 fine and a five year prison
sentence and revealing a defect in it if
that defect would help someone bypass
the DRM is also a potential felony under
the DMCA.
And one of the things we know is that
security researchers are killed from
coming forward with reports
of defects when they just,
when there's a potential DMTA overlap
or computer fraud and abuse act overlap.
And so now you have this spreading
attack surface of devices that because
they're designed to be extractive of
their users are also off limits to
independent scrutiny
and they are much more,
they're more and more intimately
connected to our bodies. And so, you know,
your car is a robot you put your body
into that then goes down the road at 60
miles an hour or if it's like the five
that goes out into five miles an hour.
But you know, it's still like, you know,
and I'm not talking about a self driving
car, I'm just talking about like a car,
right? Because you take all
the informatics out of a
car and it becomes a nerd,
right? The most salient feature
of that car is it's informatics.
Compromising those informatics allows the,
the a compromiser to wreak havoc on the
person whose body is trapped inside this
fast moving robot and on
the people around it. Uh,
and so I wanted to illustrate this idea
that as our property interest in the
things that we own is being eroded
and as our ability to independently
scrutinize them are being eroded,
that we are also magnifying all of the
imbalances and inequalities in our world
and that it happens first to the
poorest and least powerful among us.
But it spreads to everybody,
right? You know, the,
the user adoption curve for controlling
technology is like refugees,
prisoners, children, poor
people, uh, blue collar workers,
white collar workers, right? Like that's
the, that's the adoption curve. And like,
if you want to know what your life
is going to look like in 20 years,
just look at what we're
doing to refugees today.
And that's the technology that people
will expect you to use. You know,
when people didn't have
CCTVS recording them,
non consensually operated
by third parties,
unless they were in prison
in our lifetime right now,
it's ubiquitous.
Illustrating that and using this specific
group of people to illustrate it, uh,
was, was an intervention in that.
A way to try and interrupt that.
Well, let's dig a little deeper into
that idea of inequality. It's a,
a major part of this story.
The main character Selema it's
an immigrant or refugee. Uh,
the people that surround her are
largely poor and underclass. Um,
what do you think that brings the work?
One of the most salient facts
of our moment is inequality.
Uh, in part because it,
it breaks apart the story
that we've told about markets,
which is that markets are dying,
odd dynamic way of finding people
whose ideas would create more general
prosperity and allocating capital
to them so that they can do it.
And when you see widening inequality
and stagnation in our, um,
social relations,
you're left with either one
of two conclusions, right?
Either markets aren't working the way
they're supposed to or eugenics is real.
And there is a 1% of people who are
so smart that they should just own
everything. And if we would
just give them all the stuff,
they will allocate capital so wisely
that we will get richer and richer and
richer. And you know, the
history of antitrust is full
of counter examples, right?
Like when we broke up the phone
company into six companies,
they got bigger and aggregate than they
were as one from right when they broke
up the railroad and to, you know, the
railroad monopoly institute companies,
each one within a few years was as big
as the parent company had been. You know,
the disaffection of scale are,
are actually pretty well understood.
But you know,
as Upton Sinclair said,
it's impossible to get someone to
understand something when their paycheck
depends on them not understanding it.
And if you are someone who benefits
from the concentration of wealth and a
single firm,
uh,
the fact that we as a society
will benefit more if that firm,
we're broken up into smaller pieces and
each of them was allowed to compete and,
and grow is not very relevant to you
because it means that you get a lot fewer
ivory handled back scratchers. And so, um,
I think that like one of the corrosive
effects of inequality is that it drives
rich people into believing that
they have good blood, right.
And to believing in eugenics.
Um,
you actually heard this in
the last election cycle.
Trump repeatedly talked about his good
blood, right? It's like, it's like,
it is like, uh, uh, for,
for people who remember the
horrors of the Holocaust or,
uh, who've, who are Tuskeegee or,
you know, the eugenics movement,
good blood is like a, it's a, it's a
scary thing to hear someone talk about,
right? Uh, it is like, it is, um,
it's like the smoke from a,
from a horrible fire that is smoldering.
Uh, and I think that, you know,
we're,
we're blowing on those coals.
And so by writing about people who have,
uh,
who would be really efficient
capital allocators, right,
who are doing really interesting,
dynamic,
exciting things that benefit other people,
but who have,
who are denied access to capital,
one of the things that you do is you start
to change the narrative we have about,
about whether capital
allocation as efficient and
whether inequality means that
we are actually, um, just
taking random lottery winners and
heaping enormous riches on them to the
detriment of their soul and to
the detriment of our society.
Your Twitter handle currently
is son of an asylum seeker,
father of an immigrant.
Yeah.
Do you feel a personal connection to
that experience? I do. You know, I, um,
I lived in England until three years ago,
so I was,
I was in the UK until in the
run up to Brexit. And, uh,
I would end up in a lot of cabs and
lung cab drivers are a notoriously right
wing and notoriously Gabby.
And given that the,
the impending crisis was about migration
in this debate was going on about
migration,
like at least on a weekly basis,
someone would start talking to me
about asylum seekers and migrants.
And my dad was born when his parents were
living in a displaced persons camp in
Azerbaijan. They were
Red Army deserters. Um,
my grandmother had been a child
soldier in the siege of Leningrad.
They came to Canada as asylum seekers.
And then I'm an immigrant, right?
I'm a Canadian who then lived in the
United Kingdom and now I live here on my
daughter is an immigrant.
And, and I found that, like,
it gave me a place, a way to enter that
conversation. Right. And say like, I am,
that's who I'm, I'm the person you talking
about. Right. I, that's, that's me. Uh,
one generation that it, they'd say, oh,
but you're the right kind of your
high skill to your, you know,
whatever your white, uh,
and I would say like,
so my grandparents were not high skills,
right?
My grandmother stopped her
formal schooling at 12.
My grandfather stopped his at 14.
Um,
they came to Canada
without marketable skills.
They learned skills when they got
there. And this is the, and you know,
they had to display an
awful lot of plucking,
get up and go to get from Azerbaijan
to Canada. Right. Like that,
that they have the winnowing function
they went through was not passing a
standardized test or
displaying a credential.
It was crossing Europe.
Right. Like that is, uh, that,
that is an awful lot of gumption.
Right?
By the time you get to the port of
Hamburg and you present yourself to a
Canadian immigration official,
you are like,
you have already demonstrated an
enormous amount of pluck. Uh, and,
you know, they were traumatized and they
had lots of problems in their lives,
but they were also,
they were also people who came to
contribute and whose families contributed
through the generations.
And so as the debate about migration and
asylum seekers and immigrants took off
here, I felt like, uh, you
know, my passing privilege,
I have an accent that sounds
like it could be from America.
I have a skin tone that makes
me look like I could be white,
even though the people I come from,
we're not thought of as white when they
got to Canada. They certainly are, are,
are white now. Uh, and, um, and,
and so you could,
you could think that you were talking
to someone who wasn't an asylum seeker,
who wasn't, uh, the, uh, the father
of a migrant, you know, as they say,
Canadians are like serial killers.
They're everywhere and they
look just like everybody else.
Uh, I wanted to wear
it on my sleeve, right.
To make people confront that they were
among people who were the kind of people
they were demonizing.
In the beginning of the talk,
you mentioned how the stories and
radicalized aren't connected. Yeah.
But you said that the,
the role of place mattered in the stories.
This story takes place in suburban Boston.
Why Boston?
Although it touches Phoenix, right?
Phoenix isn't all the stories.
So Boston in part because I I
knew at reasonably well, uh,
I'm a MIT research, uh, MIT
media lab research affiliate. Um,
you and I hung out in Boston. I stayed
on your living room in Boston once. Uh,
and Boston's a really interesting
town in that it's like,
it's a crossroads for a bunch of
different kinds of industry and activity.
So it's obviously an academic hub.
It's a tech hub. It's now biotech hub,
but it's also a light industry
town. It's a port. Um, it has,
it has all of these different
contradictions and it
at similar to La, right.
It's not just,
it's not like the bay area,
which although the bay area has a
bunch of industries and its history,
it has been completely eclipse.
Now.
There's just like one thing
that it's known for now,
whereas Boston still is this very
diverse place. Um, and Arizona I,
I'm really interested in,
because like on the one hand,
it's a place that is not going to
survive climate change gracefully, right?
It's like, it's really in the crosshairs
of climate change, but it's a red state.
So it's also a state where
climate is officially denied,
but it's also a state that is
majority minority. Um, and,
but for a little bit of Gerrymandering
here in a little bit of voter suppression
there, um, it would be a place that that
would have a very different politics.
And it's also a retirement hub.
So it's a place that's full of people
who aren't Arizona's making claims about
their native rights right there.
They're indigenous rights as Arizona's,
even though they're all transplants.
And so like the contradictions of,
of Arizona are so, are
so vivid. And I, I'm,
I'm an advisor to a center at Asu that
does science fiction to talk about, um,
other disciplines. And so I go
to Phoenix periodically, uh, and,
and also it's my hub because
I fly to Burbank airport,
I live in Burbank and so everything
starts Phoenix and then somewhere else.
So I really was interested in the role
that Arizona plays in the kind of the
future of our politics. And
it's interesting leveling
effect if you talk about,
you know,
kind of redefining who we presumed to be
a refugee or an immigrant both places.
Both of those places are also
places that despite their diversity,
we don't necessarily think of
as an immigration. Yeah, yeah.
I think we'll see more places like that.
And I mean,
Greenpoint Brooklyn is still predominant
Polish entry point in the country,
uh,
grilling among population in Wisconsin.
What do you think that
means kind of to the,
to the sense of place and then the
diversity of those communities?
So this is a really interesting question.
We have a story about America,
about kind of something between
assimilation and ladder kicking, right?
Like once there were poles who were not
thought of as as white or American or
Italians,
and then they assimilated and then they
became respectable and then they kicked
the ladder away and they turn on
the people who came after them.
And there's a certain
amount of truth to that.
Some of that though is associated
with economic dynamism.
So one of the things that,
um,
that made people go from
being other to being, uh,
accepted as fully paid up Americans.
It was an extraordinary degree of social
mobility at various times in America's
history.
Uh,
and Tom Piketty and his book capital in
the 21st century talks about America's
dynamism and he chalks it up to these,
uh,
reset events that America had in terms
of its wealth distribution. So in,
before manumission,
the vast majority of American wealth was
in people who were claimed as slaves by
people who had enslaved them,
right? Like the, the, the,
the gross national wealth of America
was primarily in human bodies.
And so manumission in addition
to doing a lot of other things,
politically had this huge economic,
what was this huge economic moment in
that the greatest concentrations of wealth
in America sees to be considered
as assets and became human beings,
at least as a legal fiction,
not withstanding Jim Crow and whatever.
But one of the effects of that is that
the grip that wealthy people had on
political outcomes completely changed
as after the civil war because they just
didn't have as much money to
spend, right. That the, the,
their wealth was like
radically diminished.
And then it happened again during
the crash. And so the, the,
the 30 the warriors and also the echo
and the crash after the gilded age
completely leveled out
the wealth distribution.
So the amount of wealth control by
the top decile of Americans just,
just like nosedives twice in
American industrial history.
And it only happens once in Europe, right?
It only happens with the, with the, um,
with the warriors, with the two
wars in the interwar years. And, uh,
that when, when the capital
is more widely distributed,
you have more pluralistic choices,
more pluralistic decisions. Um,
which creates things like, um,
a better social safety net,
a better quality of schools, cheaper
and wider access to education and so on.
And this lifts up lots of people,
right? It helps people, um, uh,
enter a kind of middle spot.
Middleclass respectability. Uh,
and as we know from the crisis of 2008,
the first people who get jettisoned when
the economy starts to sink are the last
people who got in.
And of course there was still historic
problems with this in terms of red lining
that denied access to African Americans
to, to that shared prosperity.
But nevertheless,
you got people who became officially
American instead of others instead of
perpetual immigrants.
And so there's this story that goes,
if you come to America
and you just hang out,
your kids or their kids will be Americans.
They'll see thinking themselves as
Polish Americans are Italian Americans.
But really what we're saying is
there'll become middle class, right? And
right now it's looking
like that's ended right?
That you don't become middle class.
If you show up in America with you know,
nothing but nothing but the shoe
leather on your, on your feet, you just,
you just stay outside of
wealth accumulation and
instead of social mobility,
because all of the policy
levers that we're used to,
to allow people who had aptitude to gain
access to education and capital and to
start businesses and so on.
Those have,
those have been snuffed
out one after another.
As the concentration of wealth of
the top has grown. And as the Paula,
they have more policy levers to
yank on to increase their, their,
the concentration of their wealth
at the expense of everyone else.
And if you think about it, you
know, the law of large numbers,
the law of small numbers, making
the wealth of someone who, who,
who owns almost everything
grow by even 1% is hard. Uh,
making the wealth of someone who owns
almost nothing double is easy. Right?
That's why I like startups
have incredible growth, right?
We went from one user to two. That
is a very impressive growth, uh,
number expressed as a percentage.
It will take a lot longer for
Google to double its users, right?
Then the startup that goes from one to
two, and so if you're making the rich,
the super rich richer, even even a
little bit richer, measurably richer,
it has to come at the expense of nearly
the total net worth of a huge number of
people.
That's why that Oxfam,
number of the number of billionaires in
a bus it would take to represent half
the world's wealth is
so shocking because it,
it doesn't just mean that they got richer,
it means that giant number of people
had to get much poorer. Right?
And so anytime you see the wealth of of
the top decile of the top percentile or
the top 10th of a percentile increasing
measurably, you know that, that you know,
it's not coming from growth.
I mean there's some growth but it's
not coming primarily from growth.
It's coming through through redistribution
and that redistribution is upwards
and it's vastly asymmetrical.
Everything you own going to make a tiny
difference to someone who already owns
nearly everything.
We've long thought that technology will
help where away the differences between
class,
between race and in the story the
poor have access to technology,
but they don't have a choice of the
technology that they can access.
And there's a moment in the piece when,
when I laughed where when,
when asked what kind of toaster
the startup employee had, he said,
well not that kind of toaster.
And so the better off could
choose what tools they use your,
could you talk a little bit about,
about that element of choice? Yeah,
I mean I think that there's a,
there's a common pathology
among technologists,
especially those who work
on restrictive technologies,
which is that we never imagined
ourselves using them. Uh,
we imagine them being deployed on others.
We, we will always have root, right?
We will always,
like this is,
we were just talking before we came in
about this story today about youtubers
being extorted by fraudsters who register
fake copyright strikes the fraudulent
copyright strikes against
their youtube accounts and then
say,
give me $150.
I'll put a third strike on you because
everybody knows you can't get anyone at
Youtube on the phone when you've
had a copyright strike against you.
Because like literally anyone who
gets a copyright strike against them,
things that they, that, that
it's illegitimate, right?
So like youtube doesn't have any great
way to triage it and you just get stuck
in these support email loops and
there isn't a support choice for,
I'm being extorted by a petty grifter
who wants a millionth of a bitcoin to get
away to get my, my, my
copyright strikes removed.
And so since that doesn't exist in
the email loop, you can't get help.
But if you are me and you know, Googlers
like that would never happen to me.
Right?
I would just call a Googler friend Fred
von Loman who runs copyright for Google
with, with a couple other people
used to work with me at eff.
I could just call him and he would
sort it out for me. So, you know,
when we're in these situations,
when we design these systems,
we always know that like, they're
not going to bind us. You know,
I worked on this DRM standard trying to
fight it a for digital television called
the broadcasting broadcast flag.
And it's the crazy idea,
and I don't want to go
into the whole thing,
but part of it was that all general
purpose computers would have to only have
outputs that were approved by
movie studios. Uh, and uh, but,
um, there was a professional
tools exemption, right?
And so there were like people from all
the big tech companies and people from
all the big movie studios and people from
all the big like consumer electronics
companies in the room.
And as soon as they said it,
but there'll be a professional tools
exemption. Everyone like, yeah,
of course there'll be a
professional tools exemption.
You think I'm going to use this stuff?
No Way. Right? Like, I'm going to have,
I'm going to have the version of this
that isn't, you know, terrible. Right?
The terrible version is for other
people. Um, and so, you know,
trying to like kind of
tease that out, right? This,
this idea that like when
we make technology that we
would never want to use,
we're a dooming lots of
other people to using it,
right? Uh, you know, the, a recurring
version of this as every time people says,
well,
you know,
all those people who work in Silicon
Valley don't let their kids on phones, uh,
you know, or watch youtube
or whatever, you know,
use it on a or are they all have
ad blockers installed or you know,
all the other things that we know about
technologists and I'm guilty of a to uh,
that, that um, you know, civilians
don't have access to or don't,
don't get to do.
And also reminds me of that when we were
talking about before the talk in terms
of just how beautiful it is
when something just works.
The book also addresses kind
of functionalism and there's
a couple of neat lines
in the story.
This was a new kind of toaster,
a toaster that took orders
rather than giving them.
And then also if someone wants
to control you with the computer,
they have to put the computer
where you are and they are not.
So you can access the
computer without supervision.
Can you talk a little bit
about functionalism and
how we might be moving away
from that are closer to that. So the
nexus of control is the key thing, right?
All that,
the difference between Utopian dystopia
is who's got their finger on the button,
right? Like having a, a fitbit that
tells you how many steps you've walked,
leaving aside the problems with the
sensor and the fact that it might think
you've walked 1500 steps before
you get it a bed. Um, but having a,
a fitbit that helps you track
your own fitness levels.
Maybe you could have a pathological
relationship with it, but there's no,
there's nothing wrong with you
knowing more about yourself.
Having your boss put a
fitbit on you and say,
if you don't get your 10,000 steps in,
we're going to,
we're going to take you out of
the company health plan. It's lit.
It's the same technology. It's just
a different nexus of control, right?
And if there's,
like,
if there's a mechanism in the fitbit
that detects spurious sensor events in
order to stop the fitbit from telling
you that you've walked 10,000 steps when
you've really only just gotten out of bed,
that's great.
If that same sensor is used to stop you
putting your fitbit and a sock and stick
it in the tumble dryer to fool your
boss into thinking that you've done your
10,000 steps, that's terrible.
Right? So the best example of this,
Doug Rushkoff just wrote this
column about going to this um, um,
hedge fund conference and one of the
panels was on what to do in the event,
right? The, when the collapse comes and
the poorest come to eat you. And um, they,
they,
they were talking about this problem
that they would have when currency
collapsed,
which is how do you stop your guards from
killing you if they don't need you to
pay their paychecks? They said,
well, we've got it sorted out.
We're going to have these like two
factor biometric and, and a secret, um,
food lockers.
And so they'll have to keep me alive to
unlock the food lockers so they don't
starve to death.
And that's going to be the thing that like
keeps my guards in line. And you know,
I know people and I have been on many
diets and sometimes those diets involve
not eating certain things. And if I put
a lock on my fridge that I can control,
that didn't open until it was lunchtime.
Literally the same technology.
And the only difference is
who's pushing the button, right?
The difference between Utopian
dystopia is who gets to decide. It's,
it's where the choices. Um, and so these,
these people are moving from a situation
where the technology that they're in is
a stricture and it becomes an enabler.
And I think that there's a story that
like going back to the dishwashers and,
and,
and the Steve Jobs figure,
there's a story that we tell about
technological inevitability, right?
Like we have to make it impossible and
illegal for you to reconfigure your
devices or they won't work
or they won't keep you safe.
And we talk about it as though it, it, it,
like someone came down off a mountain
with two stone tablets that said that,
right? Like, you know,
when we talk about, um, uh,
online surveillance ad tech and, and
predictive markets and machine learning,
right?
Like I am old enough to remember when
we rotated our server logs instead of
mining them for market intelligence,
right. There's like no reason.
Like nobody will take away your cs degree
if you start rotating your logs again,
right. Instead of saving them, right?
Like that is a choice someone made,
but we disguise it as a
technological inevitability.
And so by like showing that when
the nexus of control changes,
the nature of your relationship to the
technology changes and the thing that you
didn't like about the technology turns
out to be a thing you didn't like about
the nexus of control.
That is, I think, again,
a powerful lesson to encourage people
to understand stem and there and,
and to become masters of their technology.
We talk about stem education as though
it's just part of the like normal grift
of like if you don't get your kids to
do this and give me money to teach your
kids to do this,
your kids will be economic roadkill.
And there's certainly an a certain
element of that. But again,
like I think the origins of the stem
education movement are about digital self
defense.
Not about,
not about like creating an industrial
workforce right program or be programmed,
learn how to use the technology
or the technology we'll use you.
And that empowering message of technology
is one that I really firmly believe
in. Right? I don't want
to get rid of computers.
I just want to change how we use them.
I want to talk a little
bit about the audio book.
So this novella came out yesterday.
Yeah,
there's stories are coming out in March
19 and the voice actor who did this
one's pretty interesting, just herself and
so on. Ask you about her. Uh, let me see.
SOC is a Palestinian American actress
and playwright and founded a production
company dedicated to Middle
Eastern theater arts.
How did you connect with her and
get her involved in the project?
I'm lucky enough that I've been really
involved with the production of my last
several audio books. We record them at a
studio near me in there in Hollywood, uh,
called sky boat media. So they consult
me on casting choices and so on.
And my hard and fast rule with them was
that I wanted a voice actor who was of
Arab origin.
Uh,
and I wanted a woman because the narrator
is a woman of Arab origin. And um,
you know, I have a friend Lexi Alexander
who's a very interesting person.
She's a director now, but she
was a world champion. Kickboxer.
She's a German Palestinian woman who
was brought here by Chuck Norris to help
train the army. Uh, she became a
stunt woman, then became a director.
She directed punisher.
She directed a couple of super girls.
She does all kinds of stuff.
And one of the things that she's always
on about on Twitter is all of the
talented Arab American woman actors and
other actors of color who could be doing
the roles that for reasons
that completely baffled me,
are not going to people who they
would be suited for. And so, um,
I asked her for some names, none
of them could do it. Uh, but I,
then I went to the,
to the directors and I said,
we really need to cast an Arab American,
a woman for this and um,
or a woman of Arabic origin.
And we got the demo reels for four or
five of them and let me was the best one.
And she was available.
And the arrest happened there.
I was in the studio everyday
when we were recording.
She did an amazing job and
it's a wonderful listen as
well as a wonderful read.
Yeah.
Questions from the audience.
If we can alternate between people who
identify as women and identify as men or
nonbinary and can go at any time. But,
um, that way it's not just, um, dudes.
Uh, so a lot of science fiction
writers, um, I'm thinking of, uh,
like Ray Bradbury and Isaac Asimov
and so on, kind of like, right.
A lot of stories that,
that sort of come to imagine a quart of
shared world of the future, right? That,
and they build up this kind of consistent
world of the future. Uh, uh, uh,
Ray Bradbury did what they did that
with Martian chronicles and, and, uh,
asthma for the foundation and so on.
And just kind of curious if you see
yourself stumbling toward that or,
and you might be doing that on
purpose or that kind of thing.
I liked the way Brad
free did it more than the way
asthma affected because it's,
they're not all in the same continuity,
right? There are things that like,
there are things that happen on Mars
in one story that if they happen,
then the next story doesn't make sense,
right?
But where it makes sense to overlap them,
he does.
And another writer who does
that really well as John Farley,
who has this whole long cycle of stories
that he's been writing since the 70s,
they're amazing. Uh, about, um, I think
they're called the six world stories. Uh,
earth becomes uninhabitable, are living
everywhere except earth. Uh, and when the,
when continuity makes sense,
he's got continuity and
when it doesn't, it doesn't.
And I love that because,
you know, uh, there,
these aren't alternate history, right? Or
like these aren't history. They're not,
they're not instructions.
They're not predictions.
They're artistic works.
Who's effect is, yeah,
there's some like continuity is, is
part of the effect of it. But, um,
the themes of the characters and the
kinds of characters they are and the kinds
of things they get up to are
more important than, you know,
making sure that if someone does something
in one story and then they appear as
a big character in another story, that
it's still crosses over. Uh, you know,
I think of the way that the reboots
of the shared worlds of the comic book
companies have worked where when
it makes sense, it makes sense.
And when it doesn't, it
doesn't, and they, they,
they can have multiple parallel timelines.
Like,
does anyone think Batman
would be better if,
if we were all in continuity since the
first detective comics, you know, uh,
the, the reinvention is actually super
important and part of the way that we tell
stories anyways,
right?
Like if you look at say the
all the different versions
of the Icelandic stories,
right? In the north stories,
they're like they are,
there are multiple irreconcilable
versions of what the nurse did.
There's two versions of
genesis in the Bible, right?
Like the first two chapters of, of,
of genesis tell completely opposite,
non reconcilable, mutually exclusive
stories of where the earth came from.
Right?
So you see yourself as,
as kind of interested in thematically
consistent culture but not necessarily a
logically consistent.
You can't quite say it that way.
And I'm a Pantser, not
a plotter, right eye.
I'm not someone who does a lot of card
tricks in the dark to try and figure out
how the plot's going to work.
I figured out as I go.
So it doesn't really lend itself to
that kind of continuity. Who's next,
what you were saying about digital
self defense? Um, I was wondering,
do you see that as actually being doable?
Because I'm pretty tech
savvy and you know,
at home I run Linux and I have a,
I have my hard drives are
encrypted with locks and so on and,
but there is no way I could possibly run
down all the attack vectors even on my
own machine. Sure, sure.
Yeah.
And I think that um,
there is a story we have about like
what the early days of the Internet
Liberation Movement or a unit,
techno,
techno politics movement
was that I think is wrong,
but it's got a little kernel of rightness.
The wrong version is we used to think
that technology couldn't be possibly used
to do harm and so we wanted everyone to
use technology and we didn't care how it
was used because we were sure that it
would just make everyone's life better.
That's clearly not true.
Right?
Like you don't found electronic
frontier foundation because you think
everything's going to be great.
You found it because you're worried about
how terrible it will go if it doesn't
turn out great. Right. You, you, you
see on the one hand, the promising,
on the other hand,
the peril,
but the cypherpunk movement particularly
did have this idea that you could throw
encrypted communications,
create a parallel universe where even
if you lived in a totalitarian are
unaccountable system where people could
operate with impunity and do terrible
things to you.
That because the ciphers worked and
the keys couldn't be brute forced,
that you, that you could in some way
resist the state kind of indefinitely.
Like you could have a demi moaned that,
that existed alongside of it.
And I think that not every,
not every cyber cypherpunk felt that way,
but a lot of them did.
And I think that that's wrong.
But I think that what we've learned
about encryption and its relationship to
unaccountable authority and illegitimate
authority is that encryption is,
it's it, it's like a stop gap, right?
The technology is a stop gap that you
can use to organize and to resist a
coercion while you figure out how to
make the power structures that you're
organizing about and that you're worried
about coercion from more accountable.
Um, but that, you know,
technology alone can't do it.
But if you try to imagine the inverse,
right?
Imagine creating a political movement
that holds power to account and demands
accountable at legitimate
exercise of authority.
But that doesn't use computers,
right.
That would like you find
each other by like, I dunno,
stapling photocopied posters to,
to telephone poles and imagine how
easily you would be outmaneuvered by the
force that you're trying to
resist. It seems like obvious
to me that that's, that,
that the power relationship dynamic
that we're in now is using technology to
open a space to make a political
change that gives us the space to make
technology that opens the space to make
political change, lather, rinse, repeat.
And you don't always win,
but not, uh, you know, not,
not to just create this Debbie
Monde. And you know, the,
the good news is that people's direct
experience of the way technology can,
a force for liberation and
the way that technology,
when abused can be a force of terror means
that people are actually caring about
the problems a lot more. It's, you know,
you can make an analogy here
like climate change, right?
Like if you are the world's greatest
recycler, it wouldn't stop climate change.
There is nothing you can personally
do that changes climate change,
that that will change the facts of
climate change. But you and everyone else,
you know,
and everyone they know all working
together can do something about climate
change, including collectively recycling
and making a lot of other choices,
including choices about how we invest in
maybe a green, new deal and so on. Um,
and for a long time our biggest problem
was convincing people that climate
change was a problem.
And you know,
we see today that even among the people
who've been historic climate deniers,
that's not really a problem anymore.
We're way we are like past the
point of peak indifference.
But the reason we're past the point of
peak indifference is that the number of
people for whom the reality of climate
change is undeniable because they,
or someone they love has had their lives
harmed or destroyed by climate change
is only growing,
which means that we move from the
problem of convincing people to that that
climate change is a problem.
Now we have to convince them that it's
not too late to do something about it.
And I think we are, we've gone through
that same trajectory with technology,
right?
Convincing people that how we regulate
technology matters that's taken care of
itself,
right?
We just the the largest
petition and Internet history
is the one to overrule the
electoral college and make Hillary
president trailing it by like 1% is the
petition from the European Union to not
pass the copyright directive that would
mandate content id for all
public platforms. Right.
And like that's crazy,
right?
Like the number of people
who pay attention to American
presidential politics
versus people who care about whether or
not we're going to have upload filters
is now nearly a parody.
Right?
So now we just have to convince them
that it's not too late to do something
about it. And, and,
and the doing something about it is the
making the power accountable and so on.
Not that,
not that we should ever be storing
passwords in the clear because everyone's
accountable, but that, um,
we can store passwords in an encrypted
form and also assume that the secret
police aren't going to show up and make
you put it back door in to decrypt those
passwords so they can man the middle or
otherwise disrupt the communications of
your users. Right. And that's like the,
that's the cycle that we're in. Thank you.
So obviously the, the, you know,
this country has corporations
organized based on a profit motive.
Like corporations have to be accountable
to their shirt, shareholders in peace,
profits, et cetera. We've had,
we've been lucky and unlucky
with the results of that.
And in the grand scheme of things,
obviously, you know, from my perspective,
and I'm sure a lot of people that are
your googles on the good side of that,
hopefully, um, we'll
see. You know, I guess
a lot of the time it is,
I think you're right.
Um, but uh, but there's
nothing stopping, uh, you know,
kind of the way things are going for
it going badly as well even for this
company. Sure. Um,
do you think there's a way to realign
the incentives like at a high level to,
to make that less likely to make the good
outcomes more likely, let's say. Okay.
I want to talk about that European Union
copyright directive because it's a good
example of firms that are generally good
firms or firms that have done a lot of
good that are doing bad and doing
it in a weirdly dysfunctional way.
So one of the things that's weird about
the copyright directive is that the
record labels are super in favor of it.
And the movie studios
are super opposed to it,
but they're the same companies like
literally universal music wants it and
universal pictures doesn't,
and they're both sending open letters
to the commission of the European Union
demanding that they be heated.
Right.
So this is actually a pretty common
problem in the theory and history of
antitrust that beyond a certain scale
there are massive disaffiliate nccs of
scale. And you probably encountered
them working in a large firm.
Like there's a thing that's good
for the firm as far as you can see.
But at Gore is the ox of someone who's
got a lot of power within the firm. I, uh,
I had a personal relationship
with, with flicker when it
was founded. I, um, was, uh,
an Alpha Tester for the game that
it came out of game never ending.
And I was carrying on a long distance
relationship with a woman who's now my
wife, who lived in San Francisco and
London. I lived in San Francisco.
We are both Alpha testers and Stewart
Butterfield and Caterina fake who created
the gang, came to San Francisco and we
had lunch and they said, how's it going?
And I said, it's great, but we have
trouble sharing our images. And they said,
we've got that coming in. The game will
just accelerate and product road map.
And three months later they shut the
company down and called it [inaudible] and
renamed it flicker just around
that one photo sharing thing.
So I feel really close to flicker and I
watched really carefully what happened
when Yahoo bought it and flicker was the
first mobile social photo sharing APP.
And so it had the power to be a really
big money spinner for Yahoo. But Gord,
the ox of Yahoo's nascent mobile division.
Yeah. Who's nascent social division,
Yahoo's nascent, um, a
photo division and so on.
And the great beasts of Yahoo who had
the ear of the senior management who had
assembled power structures around them,
we're able to head off and starve flicker.
So then now it limps along.
It's just been popped by smug mug and
remains to be seen what its future is,
but it represents this
like failed promise.
And this is a really common disaffiliate
NC of scale, right? It's it, you know,
these firms get got bought up by other
firms who then just poison them or do
terrible things with
them. You know, as I say,
I think Google has done a
lot of good in this world,
but I think that really effectively
burying the Deja News Archive of early use
net, it's something between a crime in
a shame. You know, those are, that's,
that's a really important piece of history
and it's like a disaffiliate NC scale.
Like someone just felt like it just
wasn't important to the core business.
Well then why did you
buy it? And, and so on.
And eventually it was just kind
of starved off and vanished in a,
down the memory hole. And so, um,
one of the ways that you make firms better
is by making the amount of harm that
they can do less, right?
Because then they can't then,
then the bad things they
do aren't as important.
And one of the ways that you make the
f the harm that they can do less is by
mandating that they be smaller.
And historically,
anytime we had an industry that was
dominated by a few firms or anytime a firm
tried to buy a competitor or
anytime affirm, tried to buy, um,
people in its vertical supply chain to
dominate it's vertical supply chain,
we looked askance at that,
we struck,
we subjected it to very close
scrutiny and we often blocked it.
Sometimes we over blocked it.
There's an argument that the,
one of the ways that we got here was
that there was a constituency for this
story that antitrust had been
overused because it had been,
and they were willing to hear arguments
for why it should be dialed down. But,
uh, you know, I think that like,
so I have a friend who went to work for
Facebook and then he quit a year later
and came to talk to me and said,
you know, you're right. I didn't,
I didn't like it very much.
And one of the things that I realized
when I got there that maybe makes me sleep
better is that no one there
is any smarter than I am.
They're just as dumb as I am. They're
not superheroes. Um, and I'm like,
but of course they are right there.
They're just like you and me.
And the reason that Facebook is a bad
custodian of 2 billion people's social
lives is because nobody
has a good custodian of 2
billion people's social lives.
Right? Like, how do you,
how do you minimize the harm that Facebook
has in the toxic ways that an enables
people lives? Don't make it in charge of
2 billion people. Socialize, break it up,
make it into different pieces, make it
sell off Instagram, make it, um, you know,
make it split out.
The two functions that has one is like
helping you find people to talk with and
the other one is helping
you talk with them. Make it,
split those into two pieces because it
really sucks at like letting you talk to
people. Uh, and it's really
good at helping you find
people to talk to, you know,
whether those are people that want to
carry Tiki torches to Charlottesville or
people who want to, you know, uh,
like Joe form a little
league with you or whatever.
It's really good at finding those
people or people who have the same rare
diseases you,
it's really good at that.
It just sucks as a place to carry on the
conversation afterwards mostly because
like there's not a lot of engagement to
be had. If you have a rare disease, right?
You check in every day, things
are okay, things are okay.
There aren't blockbuster blockbuster news
that keeps you hanging out on the rare
disease message board all day. So to
you know, up your engagement level.
Facebook's to sufficiency of scale as
they take people who have gathered to talk
about a rare disease and
they throw clickbait at them
so that they stay engaged
because their KPI and their
bonus is on engagement minutes,
not whether or not you're successfully
managing your rare disease,
make them split those two functions up.
You solve the problem.
Right now you have a business that just
gets monotonically better at helping you
find people to talk with and a business
that rises or syncs on its ability to
get you to talk with them there and,
and then you limit a lot of the harm.
It is a bit of a counter example. So at
Google for example, the primary income is,
is ads. Sure. Was historically, now
it's changing, but um, you know,
that has resulted in,
you know,
things like Gmail and docs and drive
essentially operating at a loss,
right? And being subsidized
by the successful parts of
the business. Yeah. Yeah.
But Google's not a breakeven
function, right? You've probably,
you probably have some like a
stock options as an employee.
So you've noticed that the company pays
dividends and also declares a profit
every year and it,
and so that tells you that even if the
ad business were curtailed by a breakup,
it would still not necessarily mean
that the company was unable to run those
other, those other, uh,
uh, loss leaders. Right.
It just might mean that the
shareholders took a, took a haircut. Um,
and you know, one of the, there are lots
of formal definitions of corruption,
but one of the formal definitions that
corruption is when you have privatized
gains and socialize losses, right. You
know, it's, it's cheap for me to pollute.
It's expensive for you to
get the pollution out of
your tap water. Uh, but that,
that expense is diffused
across everyone who's,
who's putting filters on their tap water
and the gains are concentrated in my
hands. Well, you know,
like if the costs of surveillance,
which are real, uh, are widely diffused
and the games are concentrated,
um, it may be that, uh,
making the firm's internalize some of
those costs dial down some of the other
things that they can do,
but it also reduces this drag
that the rest of us are feeling.
So maybe with the surplus that we gain
from being lifted out of the costs of
surveillance or market
domination or whatever, or the,
all the other things that,
that come as a result of it,
um,
that that surplus can be allocated to
make up for the losses that we get.
You know,
it's totally true that iPhone
locked ecosystems allow us to gain,
got some benefits that would be eroded
if we unlock that ecosystem by forced
mature.
But I'm willing to make that trade.
It's totally true that our printers are
cheaper because our inkjet cartridges
are designed to charge us more than
vocally co for water in town, you know,
water and pigment. Right. Um,
I'm willing to like roll
the dice on that one. Right.
And find out what happens if it turns
out that like we no longer charge for
carbon toner as though
what we're plutonium tone.
But do you have an eyeball on your sock?
I was trying to figure out, whoa. No,
it's clockwork orange.
Uh, okay. Yeah, yeah.
We're at like peak bookstore sock.
So I don't know if you've
been into a bookstore,
but like that's where all the margins
are now. You talk about ad subsidy,
like the entire literary world is being
subsidized by the fact that we can now
programmatically map bitmaps maps onto
socks using weaving machines and China
and I went on a couple of book
tours in the last two years.
I'm about to go on another one.
I spent a lot of time in indie
bookstores and I have all the socks.
Are their Doctorow socks a no.
Someone should make those and then I
can sue them for my right of publicity.
Thank you. Thank you.
And if you'd like socks,
there's a great sock store not far
from here near Angel City books.
That's in that,
that's in the Venice beach sock district.
It's in the old elk's lodge.
All right. Thanks again guys.
[inaudible].